[Music]
today we're going to make it so we can
do multiple animations so animate
multiple properties of our control nodes
and we can do it simultaneously or
sequentially and before I forget you can
also get uh the source files for what
we're doing on my patreon as well as a
bunch of other G based projects so you
can check that out in the description
now in our current setup we've created
an add tween function that creates a a
new tween and then a tween property
we're going to build upon this so it's
more of a all powerful add tween
function and in that process we're
actually going to be cleaning up quite a
bit of this code so let's jump down to
our our ad tween function right here in
fact let me get some more space so it's
a little bit easier to see and blow that
up just a tad now our parameters are are
going to change because we're going to
we're going to fill this out quite a bit
we want to have a lot of different
options when we are doing our new twins
uh but for right now we're just going to
leave this B our first line is going to
stay the same because we're still going
to create a tween anytime we run this
function then we're going to delete this
line right here because we're going to
do our properties in a little bit of a
different way for our next line we're
going to use what is called the set
parallel function within the tween now
what this does if set parallel is true
it means we're going to do all of those
animations at the same time and if it's
set the false it means it's going to be
sequential meaning one animation play
plays finishes and then the next one
starts we want to be able to decide if
we want to do parallel or not in our
inspector so we're going to create an
export function for that and then we're
going to run that through whenever we
run this function we set this to
parallel and then this will be one of
our our new properties up
here and that'll simply just be a
Boolean now these are going to freak out
up here and that's okay because we're
actually we're going to delete those
eventually anyway and before we just
tweened our scale property we want to be
able to Tween a lot of different
properties and to expand that list in
the inspector so to do that we're going
to create a new variable called
properties and this is going to be a new
export variable called properties this
will be an array and within this we're
going to put some uh properties that are
typical of a control node that includes
scale position
rotation size
and self modulate if you've not used
self modulate or modulate before it it
adjusts the color of uh the control node
but you can also adjust the alpha
transparency and I think that's a pretty
useful feature so we're going to add
that into our property list and now that
that's all set up we can go back down to
our tween function and we're going to
run through these properties we're going
to run through that array with a for
Loop and for each property and in our
properties list we want to add our tween
property function so for each property
in our properties array we're going to
add a tween property line our Target
will be the objects our property will
actually be our property now we actually
have to use this Str Str function to
make sure that whatever is spit out here
is a string because it has to be a
string for to match a property and so
that's what this Str Str this string
function does it takes whatever this is
and it turns it into a string next we
need our value and now we're going to
come back to this because we need to
adjust how we're doing our values for
now we're going to put values which is
going to give an error but that's fine
and then seconds which will be another
parameter within our our
tween and then we're going to set a
transition and that transition is going
to use another parameter within our
tween function and then we're also going
to set e and that's going to contain the
easing parameter which again will be
another parameter so let's add our
seconds parameter so what the seconds
parameter does is it tells us how long
we want these tween to take and if we
run these in parallel or at the same
time that's how long the total animation
is going to take because we're putting
this as a parameter we can set this
individually for every twe we ever do
then we have our transition parameter
and that's going to take a
tween transition type which we've
already done I believe yeah up here in
our export remember we could uh take our
little enumeration here and set our
transition we're going to do that within
our parameters and then we're also
adding our easing which is the same
process so it's a tween and ease type so
this is going to throw an error
obviously because we don't have this
this values thing so this values is
actually going to be another parameter
this one's going to be a dictionary
parameter and what we're going to do is
we're going to create um separate
dictionaries for hovering hovering off
uh eventually for whenever we enter in
the animation and we need to set exactly
what those values should be and some
cases it might just be a new scale it
might be the current scale plus
something else we need to be able to
really fine-tune those things so we're
going to do those by hand uh in fact
let's go ahead and do that right now so
there's a weird thing about um control
nodes and especially when you have uh
control nodes that are children of a
parent control node and it's getting its
layout its size its scale everything
from the parents there's sort of a weird
what comes first issue whenever you you
run the scene so when you run the scene
initially it does not um have the proper
scale it's it's incorrect it needs to to
load everything and the way that the G
engine loads things it's sort of
backwards in the tree we're already
doing a call deferred meaning we're
we're waiting till everything is done
we've had to use this because of this
from Center and and changing the pivot
offset we're going to have to do this
again in order to get the proper scaling
and sizing and everything else so let's
jump down into our our setup function
which is again being run with our called
deferred and here we're going to set two
new dictionaries one for our default
value and then one for our hover values
and in fact we should
probably uh set these up as variables up
here so let's do that we'll add a
variable hover values this will be a
dictionary then another variable for our
default values
and that will also be a dictionary then
down in our setup function we're going
to populate these variables a little bit
for our default values we're going to
run through each of the properties that
we're adjusting or that we could adjust
now we've already set these properties
up here in fact we can just copy these
and bring them on
down just like that and so we're
adjusting scale position rotation size
self modulates and we're going to turn
these into a dictionary value so for our
scale for our default value we just want
to take our our
Target scale value and the same for our
position which will be the position of
our targets and then we'll just run
through and and set these also to Target
rotation the size will be the target
size and then Target
modulates now if you don't remember or
this is a new tutorial for you target is
the the parent object the object that we
are animating that we we've already set
that in our our ready function up there
and so what the default values is it's
going to be the values we want to go
back to after we say hover off it's
going to be home base we're going to do
the same thing for our hover values so
what this is allowing me to do is to
really specify how I want these
parameters these properties to to be
adjusted instead of just setting them to
one value I could add a value to the
Target position which is what we're
going to do in our hover values I'll
actually just type this out this time so
for our hover scale we just want to like
we did in the last
episode get our our scale value that
we've set in the inspector then for our
position we're going to take the target
position as the the base and then we're
going going to add to it whatever hover
position we've set in the inspector so
if we want the um control node to move
20 pixels to the right then it's going
to be the target position plus 20 pixels
to the right that's all that means so we
do Target position
plus hover position now we don't
actually have these yet so we're going
to create these in export variables
we're going to do the same for our
rotation we're going to get the target
rotation
plus we're going to get the uh we're
going to use a degree to radian function
so we can set the degrees in our export
variable degrees to radian function and
then we need a float and that's going to
be hover
rotation then we're also going to adjust
the size now the cool thing about twins
is that you normally can't adjust the
size of a child control node that's
within a parent control node it's it's
set by the parent and you can't adjust
that within the Vector but you can
adjust it in code and you can do it in a
tween so that's a cool thing to know and
we will add our hover size option and
the last one will be our self
modulate and we're just going to set it
to
our hover modulate option all right so
let's fill out these export variables
now that we've created these two uh
dictionaries that we'll use now we
already have a a hover scale and time
and trans transition type we're going to
get rid of those because we're going to
make them specific to our hover settings
because we're going to be adding other
uh animation types like um entering or
maybe a loop animation and we want to
have different options so we're just
going to delete those okay and we've got
our from Center we've got our properties
uh one thing that I did talk about
before was the the parallel animations
so what we can do is add an export
variable for that we'll call call this
Papa call it
parallel animations this will be a
Boolean and we'll set it to True by
default and we've got our properties and
in fact let's um let's use the
export group option
here so you can do export variables you
can also add this export group and what
this is going to do is kind of separate
out your your variables here here and
make it a little bit uh cleaner a little
bit more
organized so we'll set uh just a basic
options group and we'll call this hover
settings and then fact save that
although I think I do have some errors
so not not be happy yeah it's not happy
yet comment that out at a
pass and then hover scale we haven't
done those all right let's finish up our
export variables and then I can show you
how cool the export group stuff is all
right so there's quite a few that we
need to add the first one would be hover
time which will be a float set this to
0.1
seconds that will be how long the the
tween lasts and then we're going to add
hover transition this will be a tween
transition type that'll populate our
dropdown then we're going to add hover
easing this will between e type and
we're going to add hover forgot my VAR
hover
position that will be a vector 2 next
one done position so we're going to do
scale that will be a vector 2 and we
will set a default here just so we don't
get you know zero out and then we need
our
rotation this will be a float
we also need our
size that's a vector two and finally our
hover modulates and that will be a color
and I'm going to set this
to white as the the default because if
you just multiply by by white you're
multiplying by one uh so just it'll keep
the existing color we won't make any
changes all right so that's a a lot of
uh export variables we have one more
error down here and I think it's yeah I
didn't type an S got to type your s in
the ad twen so if you have something
that doesn't work that might have been
it I apologize all right so we don't
have any more errors now we should save
it and let's look at our cool groups now
so we created an options group and I
know it's a little bit small to see on
the screen maybe but we have an options
group and we have our hover settings
group everything's nice and organized we
even have our properties array we're
good to go all right so we've created
our export variables we've got all the
things we want to change we've uh
created a default hover values they're
ready to go and we've created our new ad
tween super function we just need to
connect this to our our signals which is
the mouse on mouse off what we did in
the last episode was take those signals
connected them to our onhover and that
worked fine we could do that um but you
can also Al just bind these to our at
tween and and skip that step you know
why create another step so we're
actually going to delete these we don't
need these anymore a little bit cleaner
code and we're going to
connect these uh signals to our ad tween
except we're going to need to add all of
these parameters because we've we've
created it it's actually really easy to
do that if you haven't done that before
so when we enter our Mouse we're going
to do add tween for our cable and then
we do a bind function and we probably
should uh enter this out because the
list is going to get long so when you
bind you can just list um parameters as
if it were U you know calling the
function and this is where we're going
to fill out all of these add twe values
parallel seconds transition all this
other stuff so the issue is with the
bind you don't get the
autofill so we're just going to have to
remember what we need to put in so the
first thing we need in fact let's make
that small now we can see everything
nice so the first thing we need is our
values so when we enter when we hover
over our object we want to get our hover
values so we're going to pass that in
just like
that the next one we need is whether or
not we're in our parallel so we can run
our
parallel animations
variable we're not running it we're
calling it that's going to be our true
and false now you could really you know
make an individual parallel Boolean for
each you know the hover the off hover
you could do that if you wanted to I've
just made it a global Boolean you can
decide how you want to do it all right
the next one we need is our seconds and
that will be our hover
time and the next is transition that's
hover
transition it's nice when when the
variables make sense and then easing
which would be hover easing missed my S
there we go twice I've done that all
right so now we've connected our and
tween function with our parameter values
we're good to go let's do the same thing
for our hover off just so we can
actually test this and it's the same
process so instead though we're going to
be using our default
values we'll call the parallel
animations Boolean again and we'll keep
the uh the hover
time the same and again you could create
different export variables for when you
hover on when you hover off and and have
those be different totally fine um hover
transition and
then hover easing all right so we've got
five parameters we've got one two three
four five parameters we should be good
to go actually we can actually move that
into into there too let's move that
we're going to move our connect signals
let's just do it after everything to be
safe there we go that's cleaner Okay so
we've got our signals connected to our
tween function within our tween function
we are running through these uh value
dictionaries so it's going to go okay we
need to create a tween property for
scale and then that's going to be our
value position that's our value rotation
that's our value but we're only running
through um the properties within uh that
we've set in the inspector now we could
turn off you know scale or position or
whatever you wanted to do all right so
let's test this out we have an error
let's go see what this is complaining
about I usually don't have errors when
I'm running through this um but
sometimes you do and I think it's
important to show that because sometimes
s things screw up so I'll explain what's
going on here we're running through our
properties and then for each property
we're adding this tween property
function and that's that's going to be
our tween animation we've got our Target
we've got our our string property which
again is running through those so scale
position rotation size self modulates
and then we're getting a value but we're
just passing the entire dictionary if we
just run values what we need to do is is
call the actual um key which we haven't
done so we just need to add the uh
whatever property we're in scale
position rotation what have you we'll
get that value instead so let's try that
and see uh if it does a little bit
better all right there we go let's
adjust some of these values just to show
you what we can do now so we're we're
doing a hover time of 0.1 for our new
game button let's make that 0.5
make the transition
to um back we'll ease in ease out we'll
make the hper position go 20 pixels to
the right scale is fine let's just do a
rotation for for kicks and size um yeah
let's do let's do -20 on the size there
you go I think the rotation kind of
makes it hard to see we're running all
of these animations now we're running a
position scale rotation well not
rotation anymore but size and it's
running all at the same time now if I
turn off the parallel animations these
will run one at a time just like that
and then we hover off pretty cool so you
could want to to do that individually or
all together and then let's do the um
hover
modulates just
to show in fact let's make it change
colors do a blue or something now it's
multiplying or it's adding to whatever
it already was which is orange and
that's why we're getting a green but you
do see that the the white text is blue
turn that back to parallel and let's do
transparency run that and there you go
so with a little bit of work in the uh
animation component and thinking through
the process a little bit we now have
really easy to get to settings for all
of these different animation types and I
mean it takes two seconds to to add
these an thanks for watching and as
always keep creating all right guys if
this tutorial was helpful consider it a
like And subscribe to the channel as
we're going to be covering a lot more
thanks to all of my patrons who keep the
series going you too can get access to
the project source files by joining my
patreon you can download everything
there and you'll also get early access
to my videos and sneak peeks at Future
tutorials thanks for watching and as
always keep creating
[Music]